Film Courage: What would you say is the most
common, over-used way to end a script?
Gordy Hoffman, BlueCat Screenplay Competition
Founder and Judge: What would that be?
A common way to end a script?
I don’t think there’s a real common way.
I think the endings that are problematic and
maybe a better question…I think it usually
is when a character does something against
their own motives, the motives that you just
defined for them earlier in the movie that
go against their character.
So they do something like that, a choice at
the end that makes it like “Wait a minute?
Did that just happen?”
You don’t expect them to do something like
that.
Or something where there is some sort of fantastic
ending that doesn’t anything, something
that is implausible, that is something that
is unlikely again character doing something
unreasonable or circumstances.
I mean you can look at GET OUT.
GET OUT was a masterpiece and the only thing
that was probably problematic for some people
and this is a ***massive spoiler alert***.
So if you have not seen GET OUT stop watching
this and if you’re watching this video,
you should have already watched GET OUT.
So you want to go and watch GET OUT so you
can come back and watch this movie.
So there is your spoiler alert.
But at the end of GET OUT when his friend
shows up who is the security guard it seems
like something that was unreasonable and not
logical and I think the filmmaker probably
recognized that but he had built up so much
goodwill with us that I was willing to accept
that an airline agent (he was an airline agent)
was able to some how find him and I suspended
my disbelief but that is a perfect example
of a film that is a masterpiece but even how
to end it and I believe his original ending
was something much darker and they decided
not to do that and so he came up with something
else.
He probably didn’t choose that original
ending because of a logic issue, because he
had so much control over logic in that picture
but at the end he did choose something where
we had to suspend his disbelief a little bit
but when the goodwill has been built up by
the writer so much and the filmmaker/storyteller
then we can sort of forgive it and we did
sort of forgive it.
Some people maybe not but I did.
I said Maybe that’s a little…but it is
in the realm of possibility that the airline
guy could some how track him and find him
and I could let that go.
So I think the common problems often involve
logic and characters doing something motives
and decisions that are out of character and
within the character…Wait?
Why’d they do that?
Why would they make the decision?
And to get out of the movie.